I'm Jim Puri and in final fantasy 15 I
played King Agis you have no cause for
concern or do you take heed
once you set forth you cannot turn back
King Regis is a very wise loyal
courageous ruler and he has to make some
tough decisions what stood out about him
to me was his his love for his family
his willingness to protect his people my
name is Ray Chase and I play noctus
loosest calum in final fantasy 15 don't
know about you but I'm ready as I'll
ever be
what's interesting about Noctis is he's
not your average ordinary Prince who
goes on to try to save the world he
definitely doesn't go into it because he
wants to he's going into it because all
of this is forced upon him out of
nowhere over the course of the game he
learns what it means to be a hero he
learns humanity through the course of
this game and he loses a lot to I'd like
to be alone right now
give me some space I'm sorry for
intruding on not the time well I'll head
back then night
my name is Robby Daymond and I play
Prompto in Final Fantasy 15 well when I
first read for Prompto you know
immediately I recognized his archetype
from Final Fantasy series but I didn't
want to play them as just straights
comedy relief so even though that's sort
of his function within the four we want
to be really careful to make sure that
he was grounded and human and still
believable being a real person going
through his own journey so any bright
ideas Ignis a dark one as it were a
frontal assault would leave us exposed
but if we move under cover of night we
might be able to infiltrate the base
unnoticed hi my name is Adam christelle
and I play Ignace in Final Fantasy 15
Ignace is the confidante to the king and
waiting knocked and he is very cerebral
quite funny without meaning to be and an
organizer extremely organized and
extremely capable I'll analyze what
intelligence we
available to find us away in sounds good
specs he tries to keep not and the lads
out of trouble and has varying degrees
of success doing it
I gotcha pull yourself up my name is
Chris parson and in Final Fantasy 15 I
play Gladio Gladio is a guy who is he
has a soft spot but at the same time
he's a ferocious guy that you do not
want to cross that's the thing that that
is really appealing about the Gladio
character is that he is he is a tough
guy and he he is a comical guy but at
the same time he cares deeply about his
crew he's kind of the Papa Bear of the
crew it is in receiving mercy that men
offer praise and in shedding grace but
the gods elicit worship I'm Aimee
shields and I play Luna Freya in final
fantasy 15
I would describe Luna as a very strong
woman
she's quite reserved but still manages
to give across this major passion for
everything in life that she cares about
she is this wonderful spirit he just
cares about everyone else
the king will prove himself worthy she's
informed she's educated she's an
incredible woman to play and what's your
story I'm an impatient traveler ready to
turn ship a man of no consequence well
hi there I'm Darrin DePaul and I play
Arda nazuna
in final fantasy 15 and in King's glade
the most enjoyable part of playing
ardent the writing the writing the
writing the writing the writing he's a
wonderfully written character he's very
human because he has so many different
sides he's got that very sincere in
sincerity and I adored that about him
Aden is oomiya Chancellor of nifflheim
he's just so oily but just so much fun
that day he didn't want you to remember
him as the king
in what time you had left he wanted to
be your father
My name is Matthew Mercer and I play the
role of cor in Final Fantasy 15 core
Leonys is a person who's bound by honor
he's bound by the promises he's made to
his friends into his King and he's very
much kind of a station of the old guard
well draws me to him as is his sense of
honour his sense of duty but also the
fact that failure has taken so strongly
to heart that he wants to ensure that he
makes up for his mistakes no matter what
the cost to him the King entrusted the
role of protector to you and trusted it
to me and why didn't he tell me that why
did he stand there smiling as I've left
why I think the story of Final Fantasy
15 is the hallmark of this game it
really is a classic coming-of-age story
and in the end it's Knox story but the
beautiful part about it is that his
three friends who surround him the
closest all take their individual
journeys things like father and son
brother to brother these are real-life
things that I think people can relate to
I was thrilled with how high the stakes
were always people really lose something
it's thrilling and it's sad and it's
just getting to use everything it's
heart pounding in terms of how exciting
it is it's an epic quest it's a tale of
betrayal a tale of friendships for life
and a tale of triumph against
insurmountable odds there's a lot of
that fresh delivery that creates its own
story in its own essence beyond the rest
of the series before it but also has
enough of that continued threat of love
than all the previous games had where
you feel like it's still home the Final
Fantasy series always was that to me is
a sign of a true successor to what is
probably one of the greatest game series
to hit the whole genre in market